[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
how about the time you were over at uh
Gavin's and you had the Bolivian flu and
his little [__] suck had male [__]
pug dog yeah ran up the back of the
[__] couch went to CoCo who's got his
eyes closed sleeping upright trying to
[__] it I mean just reeking a [__] and
[__] yay and and he had [__] on his
[__] shirt that [__] [__] sucking
dog pissed on your head
that was the [__] funniest [__] I've
ever seen a lot of [__]
[__] ah good times a lot of [__]
Coke was done that bill we stayed out of
that no no you never did none of that
[__] it was just it was around you yeah
I used to go to your house drink Bloody
Mary's with you yeah and be doing little
tiny bumps in the bathroom [__] hey
[__] up in that little apartment till
four in the morning how much did you
know Ralphie oh he knew I love it come
on it's Coco you know you know what's
fun though ladies when he comes in with
the rare story all right I started
throwing blow with this chick turns out
it wasn't blow it was hair on we [__]
all night he was crazy I loved it it was
tremendous all right I think that was 2
000. okay that was a great one but
that's the only time he ever put in dude
Thanksgiving was [__] epic that
Thanksgiving well with Maryland up at
Yahoo yes oh my God you did it purple he
he ate an ounce of mushrooms Lee an
ounce not a [__] eighth a goddamn
ounce I was [__] up with you he ate
[__] smoke
and and let me tell you what that I've
never seen anybody been able to do that
many drugs and stand Coco not only study
went down to the [__] or got a big
old [__] rock and eight ball all
right did that [__] and and from what I
heard blew the [__] Comedy Store away
you haven't done the coke yeah I got the
Coke and took it home I did the
mushrooms and went to the store and was
[__] lit and nobody showed up
so like you got to go up next yeah it
was [__] lit on these mushrooms and I
went up there and I just looked straight
ahead and the lights were turning purple
in the original room like that's all I
kept seeing was purple you know right
but I heard you got a standing ovation
oh my God people were calling me
there was like 19 people yeah and you
stood them that's way more impressive
than 500 people
that if you're a comic and you're
hearing this you understand to get a
standing ovation from 19 [__] people
is more amazing than getting it for 25
000 people that's easy anybody can
[__] do that all right these people
were there on Thanksgiving night and
[__] Diaz blew him away [__]
tremendous those you know you you think
about what a night that was Maryland was
all [__] up we had a blast we oh hey
it was a great time I was telling my
wife today that it's
you know we had our friend that called
today and said that somebody died and
I'm like you know how I was eating with
my wife at the time I go you know what I
don't want to see him like what's that
word when people are you're not whatever
I'm grateful okay empathetic when you're
not empathetic but life moves on if I
drank with you at a block 20 years ago
and you die I'm very sad but what do you
want me to do stop my world and go you
know and it's just uh
I think about Maryland a lot and it
pisses me off how people talk [__]
but I was telling my wife that I go you
know I see this girl all the time that
was Marilyn's friend I see her all the
time now at the store and all the times
I've seen yeah she comes over and says
hello but she never pulls me inside and
says do you still think about Maryland I
think about Maryland all the time man I
had a candle from Maryland on Mondays to
have a candle for Maryland
I changed the water for her and it's
weird how for years she used to call me
and [__] and one day I told her I said
do me a favor man stop [__] bitching
go out there and rock the world you know
you're always bitching about what you're
not getting it's not about what you're
not getting it's focus on what you're
getting if he's giving you three spots
you're getting three more spots and a
lot of other [__] people yeah no [__]
so she would she was so powerful one of
the most powerful women Comics I've ever
seen she would go on stage late night
and some nights [__] blow it up with
that Filipino dick she used to like to
suck Filipino it was like a little
sausage she's rolling around her mouth
then people you see big guys would say I
live 300 pounds they will lift me
[__] you know just dumb [__]
that would just make you laugh late
night it's so funny
what's up with you Lisa yet you bad
[__] you're going to double
tomorrow that's it they're making you do
kettlebells and you just I can't do
doubles that's crazy you missed last
week he called me tonight he's like did
he come last year yeah yeah so he goes
yeah he's got to do it well you've lost
a lot of weight since I saw this almost
100 Battles Jiu Jitsu he's been stuck at
98 because him and the wife are [__]
Savage hey it's not though it's not me
and the wife it's me in the [__] 200
300 milligrams oh please
please don't [__] move would you go
to the wife's and eat last night oh
Molly yeah first time ever yeah I know
oh wow I know so many people go on a
mole diet but I know so many
[__] that include molay in
their diet she didn't put chocolate in
it no you don't need chocolate and
[__] moles
no that's just one part of Mexico right
they don't her uh her mom and her don't
like chocolate in it so we just had that
good it's just chicken what's in the
sauce I have no idea [__] amazing
it's amazing it's a little bit of Jesus
but yeah but what's inspires you I'm
getting used to spice you know it's not
spicy at all
depending on I didn't but now I do it's
just flavorful that's what you know all
these white people are afraid of Mexican
spice if you watch Mexican Spicer food
they just put a little bit of salsa like
a little bit of do you dumb white people
are used to [__] ketchup on their
goddamn tacos they're [__] I was in
Washington and my [__] Buddy goes
let's go to Taco Time okay it's a chain
a [__] chain up there and the [__]
lady said do you want mild salsa or
ketchup on your tacos and I [__] left
I go bro if you eat that I'm gonna
[__] fire you because I can't stand
to look at your face and we just left it
there we paid for it and left it [__]
anybody else probably ain't no Taco
Cabana and he's [__] no man some potato
tacos for breakfast stop stop the
[__] kolache [__] Factory
when I was a kid devil gum was cinnamon
but it was hot like if you ate three
slices the [__] was gonna be on fire
though that's what Mexicans give their
kids when they're daycare you know we
had Atomic Fireballs that's how we had
the only time with Fireballs but you
also swallowed gum Joey you're not
supposed to smell anything that's why
your asshole's on fire my asshole's not
on fire because I'm telling you I've
been swallowing gum since day one so my
body knows how to processing them
see if you start swallowing gum when you
ate then you're [__] up I've been
swallowing gum since day one doctor
please email Joey Dennis and do what
what's he gonna say to me I've wanted to
learn how to listen I have pulled the
gum out of my [__] I have both little
pieces of gum sometimes that don't get
processed yeah out of the house or
sometimes you're gonna pull the [__] out
of you and you can hear the gun yeah
when he gets one of them good ass zits
above his [__] to come and pop it
like a foot and a half away from you so
you hear it okay he did that in my
[__] apartment after he drank all my
goddamn orange juice all right hey Draco
[__] thing always do in 10 minutes
and then proceed it to Paul position yes
and no not on his ass off in the crack
right above it so to get any pressure
behind it he had to take those big asses
go one knuckle deep hey I know all the
stories
I'm ashamed to say I used to travel by
bus to a lot of gigs Greyhound was my
sponsor for a long time Joey Express
Joey Express I would get on that [__]
downtown bus to El Paso and I'd drop you
off and pick you up the longest bus ride
I did was New York City to Dallas that
was the longest because I had nothing
going on and I'm gonna go to all the way
to Kennedy and drop 200 when I get I'm
here right here and I can pay the
express for 48 dollars I looked at just
to see just to get to Boston it's like
only like two and a half days for like a
hundred bucks
so I would never I mean if I'm just
saying if I had to you'll never have to
man I travel by bus because I own one
get a king-sized bed don't do that I
could never set up I could never sit
like that but you guys ought to jump on
the bus sometime and we do this church
at other parts of the country yeah
the bus will be here uh to tonight it'll
get in tonight from Tennessee and um and
then uh we're here we're going to be
driving they're going to be driving
around
um Wednesday and or Tuesday and
Wednesday and uh and then we go north uh
to do do some gig I don't know where it
is to be honest with you I don't look at
McDonald's I didn't travel no [__]
Foo Fighters you guys would kill each
other you guys would before you got to
the first rest stop you're you're
[__] we would hot box that bus it
would be just look bro yeah look Lee
shut the [__] up okay me and Coco have
lived in you know an apartment smaller
than this [__] Studio okay and we
were we laughed our asses off and when
the doors were open and the windows were
open because it was so [__] hot and
we couldn't hardly go to sleep because
it was noisy as [__] we put on Joy
Medina for five minutes sleepy time wake
up throw kicks for Jesus making biscuits
and I had him on the floor of futon okay
and John Wesley John wesling on the
floor and Jody Fergie on the bed yeah
14 40. you
don't kid me well not literally I'm just
saying like you'll put something on the
TV that he doesn't want or he'll start I
got five [__] TVs five [__] TVs on
that goddamn
but pick what Channel you want that's
cool I got it how many bedrooms on the
bus I've got I've got a king-sized back
bedroom that's uh that pops out okay and
then the living room pops out and then
there's three bunks it's got a uh two
bathrooms and a shower on it and
um I've got I think there's like six air
conditioners on it so if we go someplace
where it's hot like I went to Bonnaroo
this summer and everybody all these
dirty white people out there when it's a
hundred and [__] 20 degrees dirt [__]
you I took three showers a day I was the
sweetest smelling [__] out there
people were like they thought I was for
real or something I was smelling so good
okay I was doing it Jack it was awesome
everybody's boohoo and it's hot yeah me
too I'm gonna go make a [__]
margarita in my bus take a shower and
smoke a bone [__] you I hate that band
okay it was awesome it was so great but
that's how we gotta go dude we gotta go
in the [__] bus all right your baby
these would go bananas in that bus your
baby would love that like a monster
that no it's just an expired Vicodin
what do you think will happen
you know what happened let me tell you
what happened they're listening yeah
right okay what [__] happened what
happened poppy a couple weeks ago I went
swimming
Toledo and I got in the [__] plane
the next day I got an ear infection
right oh my God and I was sitting there
and I'll tell you man
I'm you know when you work out and
you're heavy you have to take a leave
sometimes or the other yeah uh the other
one
no no the other one Advil okay that's
all that works we're at this point for
big guys when you go to Jujitsu dude I'm
past that yeah and you get slammed on
your back when you go home and you eat
your lunch first thing you do is take an
Advil especially you have to train the
next day really I've never had to do all
that [__] Lee because it lowers the
inflammation you got to eat [__] uh
like smoking weed eating weed actually
takes away the inflammatory from your
[__] thing you see the Google today
anybody see the front page of uh no
Yahoo today what'd it say more people
turn into medical marijuana prescription
to them
prescriptions are down
prescriptions are going down man yeah
yeah the opiates are going down yeah the
benzos are going down listen I'm telling
you as your brother you [__] go and
you work out with any problems no
Savages down there on that night and you
walk home you can't move oh yeah I'm
sure I'll do an experiment with the
[__] I will experiment I will
give you an Aleve one night and a week
later we'll do it again and I'll give
you a chunk of real hash and you eat
that hash and you call me tomorrow when
you tell me which day makes you feel
like that's a Bruce Lee ate the soreness
nobody knew why he was eating marijuana
40 years ago Danny DeSanto said it at a
vegan thing genius that's why he was
eating marijuana because he knew that
Aleve will kill you yeah believe an
adventure lover will eat your [__]
liver you gotta drink gallons of water
if you think it'll leave you gotta drink
[__] water throughout the daytime
that's why I don't take him at night I
take them when I get home from Jiu Jitsu
bam so I'm not or kettlebells I'm not
sure an hour later whatever [__] I do
when you saw sometimes you get sore from
flying dude I just wiped the [__] out
[__] man first of all six hour flight
Lee you [__] okay all right yeah okay
you you fly and your Connection Dallas
got bumped so now you're in [__]
Chicago and you land at b-32 and yours
is uh next flight is at age 17. 15
[__] minutes and Chicago the [__]
terminals are so close together there's
no room for a [__] for a [__] one
of them chairs you can give twenty
dollars to a black guy with a golf cart
no you got a [__] hump it dude you
got a [__] bro and then if you're
hungry
listen there's podcast I know this for a
fact and you know this too they're doing
better numbers than most TV shows [__]
yeah yeah oh my God and I
I think what uh what you always ask me
what I've learned I think what I've seen
and what that any everyone on this like
sports radio sports podcast news
podcasts not yet they're they're getting
a little bit
um but they're not they the thing they
don't have is personality and
entertainment and I think I think the
big people like ESPN and Fox Sports
don't really want that they want it to a
degree but not really because comedians
oh my God comedians have taken over
podcasts it's not even close it's not
even and some of them are bad there are
a lot of bad ones but the good ones the
good ones are could that's why that
that's why Jay Moore is good because
he's he's a comedian he's entertaining
and and there's people on those Sports
talk shows that you're talking about
that are just awful and they have but
they have the ESPN voice which is
annoying to listen to so it's like it's
like almost like the athletes when when
you when they have those athlete
interviews and like oh we're just on to
the next team whatever they're not
really saying anything what would it
cost to put Lee with two
with Alonzo Bowden
okay deadly what would it cost he asked
what would it cost ESPN to put Lee
Alonzo Bowden
give me somebody
Jason Tebow Tebow you could have Ian
Edwards for soccer like there's like
there's a lot of comedians who have it's
just mind-boggling it's incredible it's
just a waste of time I'm not talking
about Joey I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about my friends
I'm talking about I'm watching something
that's unfucking watchable there was one
neon night with Derrick Rose and a white
guy yeah horrible oh my God the white
guy is terrible Derrick Rose I thought
he was hanging out with uh doc Gooden
you know he's [__] up yeah yeah
something happened to him I don't know
why and I love all that [__] at night I
watch that [__] and cheer for it there's
one show with three black guy one of
them had dreads unwatchable unwatchable
you know what that hook up for Tony
Hinchcliffe they don't have nothing for
the Smash Brothers but the Smash
Brothers aren't they doing the rest with
a video show behind them with a video
camera two in the morning this is the
[__] I want to see yeah this is why
these channels are starting to open up
watch somebody's gonna go you know what
what's it cost me to start a streaming
[__] thing so I can put three [__]
shows on it I can stream them on YouTube
Brody Stevens 24 7. you wake up with
Brody and you go it's from seven to
eight with Brody in the morning and then
like 12 to 1 the last two stops in the
knife have brought to The Comedy Store
main room or the original room and where
he goes to eat and who he talks deadly
he's deadly he's deadly because he knows
so many [__] people man I mean I
don't think people really understand I
was I was at Fox and Tom Brady walked up
to Brody Stevens and was like hey Brody
how are you and and that's [__] Tom
Brady man okay and and he was like oh my
God and and friends are doing good man
you know feeling good doing good
positive positive he didn't say positive
and Evan hilarious and he did it just
kills you I don't see it I see it and
I'm not even by I'm not even sitting
there like I'm not even close to Brody
but he's [__] funny man I wouldn't be
like one of those guys that'll go oh
look at this guy could do away with no
no listen I'm old I'm talking about
Brody Stevens and what he does on
Periscope so funny what he does on
Periscope it just you know and this is
what kills me sometimes that you don't
want to be that guy a thousand people
watching this [__] you in the mornings
he lifts weights he goes to baseball
games he plays the drums for no reason
he's in the middle of traffic just
[__] just beating the [__] out of his
steering wheel address I get on there
and smoke dope I'm just a fat [__] in
the morning talking [__] behind the bush
you know what I'm saying I don't have
the boys that's the cats I don't have a
boat but I can't smoke in the house if I
can smoke in the house I have the cats
in there every day I'd have pure [__]
entertainment every day but I can't I
know I know you believe in Jesus you
can't do that to your babies
he never came back he lost that Fang and
[__]
once you lose a friend you're like [__]
this shit's real Jack hey I this is
hilarious
I remember uh I mean I was reading Doug
stanhope's new book okay
and I remember in all the crazy [__] we
did around [__] Hollywood get here
when did you get it exactly 98. okay so
I got here
I get here January
29th of 1997. Coco okay I'm here a year
before you that's a year a year but bro
okay you gotta understand all right we
were all Disciples of them we're all
disciples all disciples everybody who's
really been on the road
so when I get here he's a big shot and
he's got a guy from Vegas living with
him that's a part-time bodyguard that's
a dance
like he's just a [__] he wasn't even
like body that's a big fat guy right
yeah yeah he died he got arrested so he
was a dunstope you know he was a [__]
dum-dum he was like Doug's gonna make it
big and I'm the biggest bodyguard he got
a big Jack and I don't like Belushi so I
get here with the broad I'm living with
this girl on the trailer we get into an
argument she throws me out I'm living
with Doug in the bunk bed no I'm living
on the couch or somewhere I don't know
where the [__] yeah Doug's dating the
redhead oh
with the girl with Tyson's wife yeah
yeah she was [__] hot though you got
to give it to her that [__] redhead
was a hot piece of ass
all right and uh dougie dougie was in
deep into that okay he was like all in
so he used to hang out at coaching
horses
I could count on my hands how many times
I went to coaching horses coaching
horses was one of those bars ladies and
gentlemen that was just real and you
felt the pain in it and I had been in
bars like that growing up where there's
bars and then there's bars where if
you're going that two in the afternoon
there's people that and there was no
light in there none and there were some
people who were in this that were
vampires but there were some people who
were in there because they thought they
thought they were cool and that was not
the place to be if you thought you were
cool they'd suck you in and spit you the
[__] out there because I did a ton of
blow in that bathroom yeah every time I
went in there it was because I was
jawing out of my [__] mind dougie
dougie was the [__] best you knew I
didn't have a out to piss in and he
would always like hey man I can talk to
you all right you're a [__] comic
let's go over to coaching horses all
right and we just go walk over to the
coaching horses and uh it was a Bud
Light and a Miller Light for Douglas
[__] and so yeah I'm very sorry about
the podcast last week guys you know it
was never my intention I had to sit here
and talk with myself with Lee and he
kept sitting there he didn't know where
he was he was tapping on the table
his nose he was [__] doing everything
to irritate the [__] out of me
but anyway now that's off my chest how
are you cocksuck it's a beautiful
[__] Tuesday Ralphie May what up hey
baby it's so great to be here in part of
the church I love it we got the got the
the new pope Coco boom boom Diaz where's
the package
Cardinals
I know what do you think [__] yeah when
you start me off with I don't know how
whatever thousands of milligrams you
gave me like I just
I like the it got to the point where
that then the nice lady at the at the
store that we go to told me I need to
take a tolerance break she told me I see
I've seen her so much that she's like
this lady the blonde the skinny one
she's very nice and I think her name is
like Skye or cute oh Skye with the black
she is blonde over black hair real cute
yeah yeah oh yeah everyone over there is
great but she's like because I went in
there and I even told you I was like I
asked for something new and she's like
well you've tried everything I'm like no
there has to be something like new that
that's more than 50 milligrams and
there's literally like I walked around
the store three times and there's
nothing that you haven't given me and
there's nothing
there's nothing strong enough in weed
stores now like I have to poison myself
with 2 000 milligrams to get anywhere
near Stone anymore like it's it's like
great yeah now you're bulletproof please
right you're bulletproof I mean [__]
with you yeah what if one of those dirty
Russian [__] suckers try to put
something in you you'd be like go [__]
yourself if you're interested Sarah yeah
I'm [__] Lee I've been flying juice
diet that when Isis comes I gotta poison
these people and you're gonna be the
only one standing everybody else is
going to be on the floor all these other
Jews
you'll be in training we're strong
is that why you go to multiple stores
like is that oh yes if that's just they
don't know what you're doing we're we're
doomsday for Preppers well Ralphie you
like I've heard I've only heard stories
about you I think it's like from Ari and
then from Joey about like you had like
before mason jars were cool you had like
a pint mice and like a gallon mice and
Mason jar of weed on the table on the
table on the table I still got it
it was close like John Pico yeah oh Pico
yeah when Sean Ross was living with you
yeah he had a [__] container in the
[__] middle it was a pound of weed it
was [__] awesome it was huge it was
one of those big ass place on Mondays
and turn off their lights turn out the
lights three ounces of this four ounce
they would sit there and go what the
[__] are you doing with this I know uh
and the truth is is that most of it I
gave it away I gave it away the clubs
would tell me like the way it is when I
get them the way there's a go he showed
up with these [__] Chiba shoes yeah
and I think it's just the coolest thing
to do you know I mean the first time my
buddy Ari shaffir of course you know all
right right you know all right
absolutely yeah okay all right first
time he ever saw an ounce of weed I
handed it to him here here I you're
hilarious I love you here try this weed
you know that we we were we were the
first I mean in my generation he
couldn't believe it in comics I mean in
2003 or 2004 I was the first one to
start making some money and that was a
stoner you know so it was like but we're
all going we're all partying okay we're
all partying Coco take this try this all
right and you know what Joey is is a guy
that will that will eat eat a girl's
[__] while melting a Coke rock on her
[__] and then reach into her pocketbook
and get hundreds okay all right and mad
that he only pulls out ones and fives
okay all right he's mad till he gets
that hundred then then oh she came I'm
out of here right but when it came to
taking weed from me I had to force it to
him he had to force it to him you did
not your pride you're like I go buy my
own weight I know you can't but here
take this
oh my God that's oh gee I missed that
[__] me too man 35
damn that was good I really missed that
[__] refund I saw him a few months
ago man yeah
he married that girl yeah yeah he had
long hair and uh he was doing his thing
you know I said he closed it down you
know it's amazing how those he was when
kushmart opened
the word on the street
from a lot of people Kush mud at one
time I'm making 25 Grand a day that
wouldn't yeah 25 [__] Grand a day at
one time how much was like a gram at
that point do you think 25. yeah Jesus
25 the Russians on [__] sunset by
Rouse were charging 30 for the rock and
roll routes right rock and roll rounds
they had they were charging 30 for a
gram of Obama and 90 for a [__]
eighth
they were straight up gangsters when
that week yeah that place on
for most what was that place that we
used to go to the pharmacy yeah but the
no it's the West Hollywood Collective no
we used to go to a pharmacy for a while
oh yeah the pharmacy where you bought
when you bought the tickets for us to go
see Clemens pitch and it was a thousand
degrees in August yeah against the
Dodgers and we bought Ralphie bought a
bag of Edibles at the other place
because the pharmacy had like ice cream
and they were going out on a limb
Italian ice and yeah but the other place
next to
the breakfast joint that we used to go
to there
the uh by Whiskey A Go Go yeah down
there is there with the black chick yeah
oh my God yeah she was fine they used to
have cakes in that way that would [__]
you up like chocolate cake they were
like 400 milligrams 400 milligrams and
I've only took them to a [__] Dodge
again and this one before you had the
tolerance for it this was way before
tolerance nice this is when you weighed
[__] and went home and cried yourself to
sleep and [__] yeah yeah
a thousand degrees you me and John
Wesley yeah and we sat right under the
sun dog with those Edibles getting the
[__] suntan and Brewing that sun was
cooking those [__] how many Waters
did you buy from the guy the Water Guy
when it came by 77. all of them dude
three or four Innings it was intolerable
it was too hot the ticket was so good
that they were bad because it was right
in the sun right in the sun yeah those
are tough in L.A especially there's
something weird about heat on Edibles
for me yeah no they make you sweat a
little yeah it makes it like I don't
know I don't feel good when I if I'm too
hot I can't do it edible I get hot like
this it's one of the weird Joey always
makes fun of me that I pass out in the
studio after the after what when it was
really hot and it was the summer I would
take my shirt off just I don't have no
idea why I don't take my shirt off at
the beach and I was taking my shirt off
here with the door open because they
turned the AC off and I was just hot at
least say it don't take his shirt off in
the shower I don't he's like Josh what's
hat
it's [__] crazy
I'm doing good I'm tripping my balls off
but
I love it what are you seeing
just a lot of mixing it's a lot of like
twirly mixing
like like swirling like this
or like that another first one like this
yeah the wheels went like Starry Night
like Starry Night ones yeah okay yeah
because this one that's badasses okay
this one's the good house
it's both it's both I don't know like
even in my pee like the last time like I
I have a picture on my phone of one time
I took acid and I shaved my my head and
my beard and I thought the hair looks so
magical and I took a picture have it on
my phone it looks stupid it just looked
like a [__] it looks like a sink
whatever worked for you that night
don't shave anything okay I'm doing your
salad oh yeah it was weird that it felt
weird wait till four in the morning when
you're having a good time shaving
eyebrow take a chance no just shaving
light brown
you were a 12 year old
[Applause]
oh my God right here Lee
I used to do that [__] to people all the
time when I was growing up putting air
on you when you were sleeping oh and
then you take a shower in the head would
fall off
oh man oh my God they used to have some
Wicked [__] they don't do it no more
people lost them remember lemon up
remember that shampoo that you put in
your hand it was lemons and your hair
got lined up what wasn't it lighting up
yeah yeah Limit Up lighting up we're
lighting up there was a shampoo in the
70s yeah it was [__] huge everybody
once uh June came you got that shampoo
and you put it in your hair and your
head got all light and [__] and you got
sexy for the summer yeah but I said tell
me like a dirty hole
was the first invasion of the dirty horn
was the lemon yeah from there it all
went downhill oh God
I gotta tell you what is the [__]
deal all right you gonna tell stories
about how how
when you go to Gavin's The Producers
apartment and and clock up a shower
I can't tell these people
you clogged up someone else's shower oh
[__] no yes he clogged it up with
what
I'm taking this [__] man I don't [__]
know dog listen he took a [__] in there
that was so good and powerful listen man
in the shower but he couldn't push the
damage I tried to put it down with his
toe and it was such a good turd it
wouldn't go down it had heart
that's exactly what happened and then he
said the Water started coming right up
on you all right
and so you want your feet in the clean
because it was disgusting you're like
I'm Catholic I can't do this and you got
out of here and you're like yeah
and then you came over to my place just
in your [__] in your in a town
Gavin's town I don't think I'm gonna get
that down back I think that became my
top all right and then you finished your
shower much
the whole face I don't remember that
[__]
I'm like my Tesla three weeks ago
at least stop [__] with the wiring
and [__] you the microphone she gonna
electrocute yourself then we're gonna
have other problems
yeah okay kid I'm okay
all right how about this one
go go go go
you did yeah oh okay all right all right
I got more all right all right how about
how about that tag watch from Gavin I
love it I know you did I know you didn't
clip it I know you didn't clip it but
you you and me were the only ones who
knew you didn't clip it
at that point in my life right do you
remember he came up to the store yeah
he's trying to get tough on me with
Keith yeah I looked at him like are you
[__] crazy
what
listen I made some mistakes but what
really happened was
that a certain girl came up he hooked up
with her right and he fell in love with
her she told her he was going to move up
here you don't remember that story but
six months before that they hooked up
Skype and they would whack off on the
phone and talk dirty to each other and
dildos and [__] you know that was 1998
yeah
Skype wasn't 10 cents a [__] minute
then you know what I'm saying so he
started getting these bills and going
all the bills are disappearing you know
who's putting these high [__] bills
on my thing he was on that whacking off
he couldn't come to the conclusion then
the watch disappeared there was like
three or four things the watch
disappeared and he came to my house one
morning
I was living with Terry I was sleeping
with Terry's and he knocked on my door
one morning that morning I looked at him
I go dogs
don't ever knock on my [__] door
again
you want to see me you call and we'll
meet you later goodbye and that was it
yeah and that what time was about to
watch yeah the watch was stolen he left
it on top of it but then he found it
that I couldn't make face right then
somebody telling anybody that somebody
saw it on his wrist and said isn't that
the watch he stole yeah he goes
uh I bought a fake one oh yeah
so wait a second you had a real watch
it got stolen and you went and bought a
fake one the exact kind of exact kind
you know I do that and we're not talking
[__] listen man I was no saint no but
you weren't that but I wasn't the devil
and you know what at that point in my
life
I was playing that role
for 20 [__] years by that point so I
already knew I grew up in North Bergen
where those guys would go
uh
uh you know [__] Ralphie
he stayed here to wait in the morning
snorting cup really you didn't help him
you didn't help him oh yeah I did a few
lines you know I mean what the [__] I
drank a few beers so it was all Ralphie
yeah right when I was growing up that
was every morning when they walked into
hashways and one of the biggest speakers
in the city they'd go [__] Coco kept
us out till six in the morning really
right you wanted it was your car yeah
you could have threw me out of the
[__] car three hours earlier but you
didn't exactly
laughs
it's just uh
I wanna I wanna light another candle for
Mama Ashley's uh rice pudding God damn
that was delicious she's still alive
what a shame you know Billy horrenda
moved to town
we talk from time to time
that's why nobody goes home no more yeah
right he goes there's nowhere to go
there's another good I mean you can go
to chance dragon in and still get a
strong aggro okay oh no no those places
are still but our base yeah right the
one down the corner where everybody went
there and got a roast beef sandwich and
you knew Mrs Harrison you could put it
on the arm for credit right and you went
behind the counter and put your own salt
mayonnaise yeah make it make it nice
pickles you know no no no no no no no no
no that was that and that's what
happened I spoke to another friend of
mine and I called
in regards to something else about a
month ago and I go you've come home a
lot and he goes
he goes after hashways closed I moved
down here and I never came back again
yeah
important
hashways was so [__] good dude you
have to get you to get you a [__] uh
was it chocolate sodas you used to get
me was it egg cream or something no use
the Yoo-hoos oh okay again and a roast
beef and chocolate water a roast beef on
on the road
chocolate milk what chocolate milk is
better than you who I think well I had
to get the full
you want chocolate milk well you want a
[__] you who you want a
[__] you I was going 7-Eleven
got you this night's I stopped here and
I go in and get a evil I'm good for the
night you [__] you who you're good
it's amazing what are you who would do
to you have a 16 aren't you
I I did I did everything that was before
one of the hashways had the lump okay
but mama still came in and great rice
pudding and then that was my first time
at hashways this is how cool this place
was six months later eight months later
I am going through and going [__] it I
don't know any place I'm going to go
into the city I don't know any place I
want to park over there I'm gonna [__]
JFK Boulevard [__] yeah man I get off
right right before I go into the tunnel
I'll go with JFK and then boom pull
right into halfways they I'm there I
gotta say hello I gotta tell them to
tell Coco they said hello and then mama
hashway not only did I get my roast beef
sandwich you made me an extra one and
then I she goes I heard you love my rice
pudding so here take a bigger thing and
she gave me extra rice pudding and one
of those cinnamon what the [__]
what's the chips that they had there
yeah wise chips with the owl right yeah
that's the ones that's the [__] ones
it's funny Lee one day we're having a
conversation years ago and you were
talking about that pizza Paul in your
neighborhood right yeah that is the best
pizza in the world to you
like to you like when you go home
no matter what anybody says no you got
to go to Johnny's on Fifth Street you
still go there and it still tastes as
good as it did when you were a [__]
kid absolutely that was hash voice only
with yelling and screaming and uh people
giving gossip and you know
man how about that heart attack on a
roll in the morning that morning
sandwich that she'd make us oh my God
you picked up two of those I mean
I started eating there you gotta figure
in 1975.
dark Rafi I went up there I was a
downtown kid and I went up there
the word on the street was if you want
to get better in basketball you got to
go up there and play the rough games in
the daytime
he was the catcher on the baseball team
by mistake slam me and he goes man I'm
sorry you know
so he got me a roast beef on rye
with Swiss cheese thin shaved lettuce
let me tell you something when I've been
into that it was all over I'd never
taste anything like that in my life
I went there every day after that too
it [__] yeah till then we did the
documentary yeah absolutely that's why
then we didn't go in that time we went
in there at two o'clock and the roast
beef wasn't ready I knew them was in
there yeah right if though what what are
you talking about what are you talking
about the roast beef used to be done at
10 in the morning earlier earlier after
eating the roast beef so it's like when
they first got us that first bounce
check you know the first time that he
would have bounced check and they're
like oh my wife didn't deposit the
phones
that first bound check means the Boogie
with noogie it's only gonna get worse
after here don't make me give you
references you know what I'm saying that
first basketball means run even if they
give you even then they'll cash it right
away they make themselves look solid
gotta
let anyone to [__] it he's got a coat on
it'll be fine he just falls down
sometimes who hasn't you know who has it
this is a very interesting night of
podcasting I have no idea what happened
what it was said I mean I think we had
fun man I know I laughed my balls off
and at least I hadn't got to scare the
snake
that was tremendous you gotta say that
for the [__] hot I real all right
dude the only the only way I'll forgive
you Ralphie is if I got a ten thousand
dollar stake at the at Harrah's with the
blackjack table not ten thousand I'll
get you I'll come on I'll we'll sit
there and I don't know I gotta start
you're Jewish relax
I'm not gonna let you know
and not [__] play with me I mean here
I'll give you money I'll keep you there
no no I'm not asking from you oh my God
oh my God
it was it was so crazy when you think
about
and am I ashamed of this Ralphie May you
know I can't lie to you no
but there was a time I was under the
credit [__] credit card dude
and I still to this day out of all this
[__] I did there's two things that I sit
back and giggle
and go how the [__] who not Hula Hands
the ground round and Sundays I look at
you as a man round round and if you
don't believe me you call George
kaladinski right now and that's my
witness all right I took Joyce to the
ground around the way I was walking you
hungry yeah come on let's take a ride
I walk into the ground when we get what
you wanted something to me
you get the soup the chili Give Them
Wings how many wings you want six give
them 12. you're like look at Joey and
also like the tab would come I go thank
you and I go start walking and you go
why we ain't paying for this
and then you're [__] accomplished no
how many times I did that I think I did
it three or four times with George leave
your getaway driver oh yeah without even
knowing it no no no no no no in those
days there was always a by the way I
would give you what you're looking for
but it ain't gonna come easy to you you
either gonna give me a ride a shirt I
gotta take a shower at your house
ain't cheap in those days
I'll give you 20 Quaaludes but listen
we're going to go to the Bronx you gotta
wait outside this black neighborhood and
keep the guy
keep the car on go lock the windows
keep it on don't open the window for
anybody
you don't need no air right nowhere
you have no [__] idea how easy it was
to make a living but I would go
in 90 no in 85 I was the worst I ever
was
the worst I ever was from with cocaine
or no no no no an 85 I was clean
I was spotless I was just smoking weed
like a [__] and I went on a six
month tear in the New York City new
Northern New Jersey area
that till this day they're scratching
their heads I would dress up in a suit
and go into office building and take
purses and that's registers
I always [__] envelopes with nothing
then I throw it away God damn it I would
bring I would go to Safeway and steal
vitamins and sell and tampons and what's
the itch when you imagine them what's
that stuff you get
yeah you steal it in Jersey for Fort Lee
and I'd walk it over the bridge the
Spanish Harlem where they pay your top
dollar for that [__] I was a walking
they did it scam it was like it didn't
stop one thing I did was I kept three
credit cards in my wallet that were
expired expired and expired one was hot
and expired like and I got away with
this for six months well that's when
they just did the paper three times a
week Lee I would eat at a fine
restaurant a tremendous lunch on the um
for free I always left the cash tip I
think they look it was never a piece of
[__] then they invented cameras because
of you I think I think like because of
people like Lee you gave them your card
and it was under fifty dollars and it
was the lunchtime crowd your restaurant
had to be packed yeah it had to be
packed if you went in there when you
were you can't look at it too long they
couldn't look at it too long they would
have to take when they had three of them
for lunch you ever go to a restaurant
they had three things in those days they
didn't call me if it was under fifty
dollars 28 32
getting called they just wanted this
ching ching you signed and they gave you
the card back did you like look at the
names and only get like a male who like
not like not like a black dude for a
week
I became whatever name you gave me
whether it was Muhammad
I was a Chinese guy for about two months
when I lived in San Francisco dog I was
a Chinese guy for at least two or three
months
because I used to go to that [__]
Japan Town up in San Francisco and they
were the only people that would take
Travelers checks without a credit card
without a license
they were in on the movement
we didn't even signed for that credit
card dude you can't you have no idea man
that's how it was you got to talk to the
people like you own The Joint let me get
that watch let me try it on all right
let me get this from what else you got
let me get that one too boom what's your
name Sam what's happening Sam everything
all right I made your day today you're
gonna make a nice commission you take a
Visa credit card American Express Diners
Club what do you think yeah here I'm
holding a Visa yeah but you know what
I'm saying I'm holding a Visa but I'm
throwing different options at you I got
discover I got Amex what do you want
I've seen you do that no dog you gotta
walk in there like you're on the [__]
place Lee
and the guy would be smiling and having
a great time you get in the car you
thank you for coming thank you for
coming Mr Kim thank you yes they're not
gonna argue with you every once in a
while they ask you for a license yeah
one out of ten times you gotta ask for a
license then you gotta run out and you
lost a credit card the credit card was
higher than hot remember in those days
it wasn't what it is now if I stole a
credit card in L.A and I sent it to you
overnight mail in Jersey you had two
days to go bananas because it would only
break down in zones so it would break
down in the west coast Zone the mountain
the the uh what I did it on Friday you
had till Tuesday you had till Tuesday
all day there was a thousand scams
remember in those days I would say to
your league give me a nickel I'm gonna
give you back 550. I gotta do that watch
me I go buy 500 worth of Travelers
checks and we get you [__] 30 cents
on the dollar whatever and then we bang
you t-shirts you have no idea at least
something let me tell you something
about for me I love you to death
because the last 20 years you made it
cool for me to be alive like you've made
it you've made it this acceptable like
when you used to go on the road and come
back two weeks later yeah I loved you
because you got me weed and [__] like
that but I really love seeing it because
I really missed you I figure without you
I'm at the store by myself I'm fighting
these [__] dude we were we were
it was me and you and that little
[__] apartment and it was just a
crazy situation that's what this began
and I would tell you [__] and we would
Giggle and it's just weird that every
time you know this the hospital the PTSD
the [__] you know yeah I was gonna ask
you Ralphie how do you like survive 20
years
okay
uh build up a tolerance to that weight
okay all right you gotta be of a month
now have you been a getaway driver yet
no no no no no
no you haven't been a getaway driver yet
I don't believe it and the Coco's not
the same Coco he was no Okay so
so will you get the Bolivian flu every
once in a while you never [__]
brought it around me no no I do little
bumps in your bathroom right now right
but but nothing disrespectful you know
like like if like when I first got here
from Houston if you didn't put out Coke
right there oh I had to die all right
but you're always a gentleman no there's
a gentleman about it I wasn't even
talking about that I was just talking
about like him torturing you like
mentally oh my God the tortures
okay all right I broke my [__] hand I
hit a guy at the [__] air I mean at
the uh at the uh post office because he
pushed an old lady down because she
couldn't hear the Asian lady she was an
old Russian lady all right and you
couldn't hear the Nets Go net please
okay and so the Russian lady was
standing there and this douchebag L.A
guy pushed her and she [__] snapped
her [__] arm oh my God yeah right in
front of me so I turned around and hit
the guy and it [__] broke my hand
okay and so
uh I go home I'm [__] talk calling
Joey and I'm shook up man I'm like Coco
is like a shark if he smells blood in
the water if you're upset about
something that's what he's going for all
right so so he called me up and go get
out of there get out of there right now
the the police are coming right now but
could you you knocked the guy out but
let's go out the back door I'm I'm
outside at El Compadre all right go out
the back door right now all right and I
ran out the back door thinking like that
and I didn't have my keys so I can lock
myself out of the back of gardener so I
had to walk all and I was you know
you're fat you're mad okay you're mad
like now I gotta walk around the goddamn
front
to get in there well I'm hiding thinking
about doing a couple went down to Josh
Wolf's House okay you know what do I do
that's what I do it's crazy how many
how many another piece in in this crazy
how many getaway drivers that did
something with
until today they have no idea when
they're yeah I think I'm in that group
maybe no no I can get away but like no
idea how fast leaving you have no idea
and um and you know what's crazy like I
remember like four of them now I don't
remember the good ones when you come
back bleeding and the people like what's
gonna happen oh you come back like OJ
yeah he has to cut your eyebrows outside
your shirt's ripped yeah and what the
[__] were you oh I had to go take my
shirt out of the laundry you [__]
[__] are you [__] crazy you
bleeding from your hand it's gas to
death man you don't leave one of those
guys in Vegas that you get them high
yeah that's really it's right you know
Lee thinks like when Lee was allowed at
the South Point Lee was very interesting
to me because
at least age I didn't like Las Vegas at
all yeah I took a hating for Las Vegas
when I was 22. and I said I'll need this
place I'm from New York City where I can
do this I gotta walk around with cameras
I gotta walk around with cameras and
they're watching the bathrooms they
watch everything yeah for me to get down
for me to come to you say in 84. I had
to know I could snort in peace
mm-hmm I could go to a bar and Jack out
like I used to do in Houston but you
can't even talk anymore I go to that
Island parking no no no no no yeah yeah
yeah [__] yeah
our house
no no the [__] other bar where you
get jaundice they had no windows that
bar there I used to walk in there and I
couldn't even [__] talk but anyway I
make a [__] long story short I know
what the long [__] story short was
it was interesting because
we would finish up a show
we would eat something we'd get high
and we would look like you know okay I
get at least tired I'm tired and the
next day I hear a tremendous story
how he got up at two
brushed his hair and came down he won
through five
at 5 30 he bumped into a friend who put
bad luck on him and he went back to the
table
and he ended up losing we ended up
losing what he won plus a hundred
dollars his pocket now he's salivating
from the mount
because he's Jewish he goes back up to
the road he washes himself he bangs with
that he calls his girlfriend and he
refused for The Last Temptation Of
Christ he's got this weird way of
gambling tonight he's telling me how
good he is he's Johnny Bananas I stalk
him I stink him a yard or two he blows
it in two minutes he got beat up
like something
till this day he blames me
one of my first couple hands
I walked away so it's my fault I never
know he's lucky
I've never been nobody's Lucky Rabbit
foot this guy wins
put him in the bathroom hi buddy we
seriously we started a new career he got
books he took it he took a [__]
course on him how to hypnotize the
Blackjack demon
if you have it
the uh I know it's actually in my
luggage I go everywhere with that he
took a course you know by the way
uh I've had okay thank you church for uh
taking me in and loving on me you guys
come to my shows and after the showroom
I'm you know downstairs maybe having a
delicious Budweiser product okay you
know maybe maybe enjoying myself a
little bit before I go home and you guys
come up to me and you're like look at
the yellow Ralphie where's that goddamn
bracelet we [__] love that and and
and it's because of this I've gotten
tons of fans and and they've come in and
they've loved me and I just say thank
you I am very humbled by y'all the
[__] church is for real dude
they do not [__] around in in Denver I
had uh I had like five guys uh go dude
I'm from the church and they brought me
reefer okay I had to leave the family
Houston Houston's oh it's in Nashville
oh my God every time I'm in zany that's
my home Club okay uh every time I'm
there every time 20 or 30 guys are like
man we love you on the church
and it's just like it's so cool that's
cool man it's like it's like it's like
the thing that we had is like that is
like just going out you know what I mean
and and I'm I'm just trying to distract
now because Coco's really getting into
his [__] left nut all right I think
you might be ready to pop his head
I've seen that look
there's nothing like me with the little
blood there's nothing like moving
and [__] uh getting like stuck in
your nut gets stuck on your underwear
you know me undies is banging I have
short time so it [__] it up
all right let me read this out we'll get
the [__] out of here
don't forget
[Music]
thank you